on va parler d'un sujet au combien
important pour chacun au quotidien les
déplacements un plan local de
déplacement sera présenté lors de la
prochaine réunion du conseil
communautaire à 50 ans en Yvelines le 27
juin j'accueille sur ce plateau Emmanuel
Véga bonsoir vous êtes directeur des
transports et déplacements pour la
communauté d'agglomération de 50 ans et
également en plateau Maylis Florian
bonsoir à vous en charge du dossier plan
local de déplacement pour la communauté
d'agglomération donc ce plan qui sera
soumis au vote des élus le grand public
va aussi pouvoir le découvrir quelques
jours auparavant le 25 juin à l'hôtel
d'agglomération attrape il y aura une
réunion d'information publique il y a
deux axes déjà pour guider ce plan
améliorer la qualité de vie renforcer
aussi l'attractivité économique on va
tout à l'heure à préciser un petit peu
les choses auparavant il existait déjà
un plan local de déplacement à 50 ans
depuis 2003 quel bilan on peut faire de
ce premier plan qui avait été mis en
place tout à fait donc c'est un plan
effectivement qui avait été voté en 2003
qui a été mis en révision par la
communauté le 24 mai 2012 et on avait
constaté qu'effectivement on avait eu
des de progression très significative
sur notamment les modes actifs c'est à
dire la marche à pied le vélo avec des
pistes cyclables qui avait été par
exemple très massivement développés
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un plan local de
déplacement un plan local de déplacement
c'est un document cadre qui donne une
vision un axe stratégique finalement sur
le la question des déplacements et du
transport à l'échelle de l'agglomération
et qui intègre tout un ensemble de
fiches programmatiques c'est-à-dire des
fiches très précises qui indiquent les
actions qui sont amener les budgets qui
sont associés et qui donne un calendrier
donc c'est un document qui est quand
même très opérationnel et qui décline
finalement des actions concrètes au
bénéfice des citoyens qui a été prévu en
2003 a été réalisé 10 ans après
globalement il a été plutôt bien
appliqué il a été comme je vous l'ai
indiqué bien bien mis en oeuvre sur les
modes actifs sur notamment le
développement du réseau bus aussi de
Saint-Quentin qui s'est très fortement
renforcé on a l'un des plus importants
réseau de bus de grande couronnes
d'Île-de-France qui est que
l'agglomération soutient très
massivement avec un budget très
significatif excusez moi et qui fait
l'objet de renfort et d'amélioration
quotidien même si bien évidemment il
n'est pas parfait et c'est pour ça qu'il
y aura encore des améliorations avec ce
nouveau plan présenté donc à
l'agglomération le 27 juin au vote des
élus question du développement durable
respect de l'environnement c'est une
notion qui sera peut-être encore plus
présente sur sur ce nouveau plan
justement est-ce que vous avez mis
l'accent sur ce point-là très très
clairement bien évidemment que oui
puisque ce schéma s'inscrit dans le
cadre d'un document cadre qui a été voté
par la Région Île-de-France en 2012 qui
est le Plan de Déplacement Urbain
d'Île-de-France ce document indique
clairement des objectifs que nous devons
tenir c'est à dire des objectifs de
report modal c'est-à-dire rendre les
transports en commun et les modes actifs
plus attractifs avec des objectifs
effectivement de développement de ces
modes et puis pour la voiture
particulière d'essayer de contenir un
petit peu le développement de des modes
motorisés et dans le PDF il est même
clairement indiqué qu'à un horizon de 10
ans ces modes doivent diminuer 2% alors
il y aura forcément vous l'avez dit
l'accent 1100 et transports en commun le
vélo également sur ce nouveau plan on va
pas détailler en entier parce que ce
serait peut-être un petit peu long mais
quels sont les actions concrètes qu'on
peut imaginer qu'ils sont en tout cas
prévus alors c'est des actions par
exemple si on prend on utilise le bus
quoditénement c'est des actions sur
l'efficacité du réseau de bus le temps
qu'on met quand on fait un parcours mais
c'est aussi par exemple l'information
qu'on trouve dans les arènes de bus
qu'on aimerait mettre en place le temps
d'attente qui nous attend pour le
déplacement pour le vélo c'est continuer
à développer le réseau cyclable mais
aussi l'entretenir parce que c'est bien
de développer mais il faut entretenir et
faire du service vélo par exemple on
pense en gare de Saint-Quentin
développer du stationnement sécurisé
avec on pourra faire des réparations de
son vélo donc c'est améliorer en fait ce
qu'on trouve sur Saint-Quentin non
peut-être pour guider vos réflexions
quelles sont les attentes des 5
continents en matière de déplacement
notre question du jour en ce 5 juin
trouvez-vous facile de se déplacer dans
l'agglomération au quotidien vos
réponses
sur 50 ans en Yvelines moi je trouve que
la circulation est plutôt fluide sauf le
matin de bonne heure au niveau des bus
je trouve que les desserts sont plutôt
sont plutôt bien il en manque certaines
le dimanche ça c'est un peu dommage
voilà puis au niveau des trains rien à
redire on a une super gare quand même
vélo impeccable il y a des pistes
cyclables c'est très bien voiture j'ai
pas le permis quand on arrive de l'excès
de la ville c'est une ville tellement
étalée donc ça pose quelques problèmes
pour se repérer parce qu'entre
Guyancourt Saint-Quentin on sait pas
trop la commune à laquelle en fait on va
arriver au niveau des transports on a
quand même de la chance à voir les
trains à côté la gare avec beaucoup de
lignes c'est une bonne circulation en
fait on trouve que il y a pas trop de
bouchons c'est fluide pas trop de soucis
les bus oui il y a un quartier qui est
pas très très bien desservie je sais
plus en quelle direction mais en règle
générale on va de partout quoi
les gens sont contents globalement tout
va bien sauf le matin et le dimanche
aussi ça c'est une question le week-end
aussi vous y prêtez attention parce que
les gens veulent aussi se déplacer le
week-end même si les entreprises sont
fermées oui effectivement on sait qu'il
y a de plus en plus de déplacements liés
aux loisirs et donc le samedi dimanche
ou en fin de journée et donc dans nos
réflexions on intègre ces déplacements
là évidemment c'est un plan qui va
permettre de une mise en place sur
combien d'années ça va durer sur 10 ans
là aussi plein local de déplacement
c'est de 5 à 10 ans suivant la
réalisation des projets et sur celui-ci
ce qui est prévu 50 théoriquement et 10
ans en fonction de l'avancement des
différents projets présentation au
public tous les détails sont donnés le
25 juin à l'hôtel d'agglomération à
Trappes pour les élus ce sera le 27
est-ce que les gens vont pouvoir
proposer des choses est-ce que les
choses vont changer ou tout est déjà
figé aujourd'hui
non les choses ne sont pas figées
puisque après l'arrêté qui sera pris par
la Communauté d'Agglomération le 27 juin
il y aura une phase de consultation
qu'on appelle excusez moi des personnes
publiques associées c'est-à-dire nos
partenaires qui vont également nous
aider à appuyer ces projets c'est à dire
le STIF la région Île-de-France le
Conseil Général et il y aura une phase
d'enquête publique et là dans cette
phase d'enquête publique là d'une façon
très structurée il y aura une
concertation très large de la population
qui aura accès aux documents et qui nous
fera part de ses avis à vie qui sera
formalisée par un commissaire enquêteur
et que l'agglomération ensuite analysera
et intégrera pour approuver un document
définitif ensuite ce document définitif
sera établi quand normalement pour la
fin 2013 de tout début 2014 et pour une
mise en route ensuite des modifications
voilà tout de suite on met en place le
plan qui sera effectivement qui fera
l'objet d'une concertation large et d'un
consensus alors l'enjeu est important
pour le grand public chacun utilise
forcément en mode de déplacement en
cours de sa journée c'est aussi
important pour les entreprises parce que
les entreprises regardent un petit peu
comment les employés vont pouvoir venir
travailler ces entreprises sont
concertées vous avez déjà échangé avec
elle on a eu des concertations
effectivement importantes avec les
entreprises puisque surtout la première
phase de concertation du PLD on a fait
des ateliers des ateliers qui étaient
largement ouverts effectivement à des
associations à des collectivités locales
et également aux entreprises et dans ce
cadre là on a eu des entreprises de
Saint-Quentin qui ont participé à ces
ateliers qui ont alimenté le diagnostic
qui ont réfléchi avec nous sur les
scénarios d'objectifs que vous souhaitez
souhaiter atteindre pour vous donner un
exemple très concret notamment sur les
bus il y a eu des objectifs notamment de
performance de la vitesse du de notre
réseau de bus vers les rabattements gare
qui sont des éléments importants pour
permettre aux salariés d'atteindre dans
un temps effectivement performant leur
emploi il y a des entreprises qui sont
inquiète aujourd'hui
par rapport à l'arrivée de l'heure
d'arrivée de leurs employés à cause des
bouchons le matin et des améliorations à
porter alors bon il y a effectivement
toujours des entreprises qui dans une
logique d'entreprise de toujours
d'amélioration de progrès et de
démarches qualité on peut toujours faire
mieux donc dans cette logique là on
travaille avec elle mais globalement on
a plutôt une satisfaction des
entreprises puisque maintenant depuis 5
ans on a mis en place des plantes de
déplacement inter-entreprises et on a
construit un dialogue très positif et
très constructif avec des entreprises de
l'agglomération ou effectivement tous
les points durs tous les points vraiment
qui étaient délégués sur le réseau de
bus ont été traités aujourd'hui sur la
question la nationale 10 par exemple
c'est un point que vous allez aborder
parce que cette nationale 10 elle est
rapidement embouteillée il y a des
travaux qui étaient prévus est-ce qu'on
élargissait est-ce qu'elle était enfouie
est-ce que les choses allaient avancer
avec aussi le prolongement de
l'autoroute c'est une question qui reste
en suspens c'est un point qui est étudié
dans le plan local de déplacement
il y a le cas des déplacements qui est
sur la question des franchissements en
fait ou des liaisons SOS entre
l'agglomération parce qu'on a la coupure
de la RN 10 plus du corridor ferroviaire
et donc ce qu'on les projets qu'on
propose dans le cadre du PLD c'est que
les ponts qui traversent ce corridor et
la RN10 puisse accueillir enfin mieux
accueillir les voitures mais aussi les
bus mais aussi les vélos qui soient
vraiment un support pour passer de l'est
à l'ouest de l'agglomération donc ce
serait effectivement aussi à l'étude et
pour tous les détails rendez-vous déjà
le 25 juin hôtel d'agglomération attrape
merci à vous pour ces premières
précisions puis on aura l'occasion de
vous donner plus de détails puisqu'il y
aura ensuite des concertations et chacun
pourra s'exprimer sur ce plan merci